après les travaux le réaménagement les
pots de peinture ont laissé la place aux
meubles et au carton rempli de livres
le personnel de la médiathèque du canal
de montigny le bretonneux devrait
s'installer dans les locaux à partir du
12 septembre
la réhabilitation a duré plus d'un an
notamment pour améliorer la
fréquentation qu'on a commencé les
travaux au printemps dans la médiathèque
et dans le musée tel qu'il était prévu
au départ dans les locaux actuels est
assez rapidement on nous a demandé de
de modifier le l'organisation des
travaux pour permettre l'installation du
musée au rez de chaussée de la
médiathèque chaudière système d'aération
ou d'éclairage tous ces équipements
techniques ont été rénovés dans un souci
d'économie d'énergie entre une journée
en plein été à midi et puis en fin
d'après midi en plein hiver l'éclairage
extérieur n'est pas le même donc il ya
une
une régulation au niveau de l'éclairage
intérieur donc on est petit capteur qui
permet effectivement de automatiquement
en fonction des limites extérieures
d'avoir une main de la rage intérieure
calcul est optimisé contrairement à la
médiathèque les travaux du musée se
poursuivre
il devrait se terminer entre le 15 et le
20 septembre sa surface atteindrait 400
mètres carrés
donc ça c'est un plan du musée là ici on
à l'accueil du musée on aura un petit
espace de projection
nous voilà en gros les expositions ça
partira de là
jusque là donc divisé en deux actions
expositions permanentes expositions
temporaires
l'accueil sera commun avec la
médiathèque
réouverture prévue pour le 16 novembre
prochain